yeah welcome to this video playing water
from Argentina there's something else
that you can play here let's try for the
virus off yeah it's a bit like a reverse
chigorin
I think I never played this opening it
really absolutely never I think you can
play like this queen d three NT forth
some more plate this against me in once
in the in blitz chess not the tournament
just and then he form and then it's very
close to a similar to to our 1.e4
position let's say e64 was so so you for
now or you know probably so very karmic
on like this position probably not not
giving word any any edge or something
with the Queen would check yeah like to
keep the bishop yeah this is a simple
approach but not a bad one hmm yeah but
I don't want to exchange Queen so early
it damn it also leads to a pawn
structure that is really am without much
prospects okay we can we can of course
play em check yeah really try to hit get
all the fun out of this position we came
so we need to play this end game here
it's not an end game but let's say the
simplified position with Queens off
yeah black has got a very decent play it
so it's fairly solid okay so why does he
move it again probably preparing the
shop to to f5 ok I want to if possible
pledgee form
so g4 does this yet it gives me the
bishop at least know yeah loh form oh
this is nice this is nice yeah this
should be a slight edge fire for right I
didn't see that of course okay yeah okay
so he's so not having this permanent
weakness but
but at least check its two bishops
okay so need to retreat him Luke h8 was
was a threat
yeah i'm not sure that Bishop g6 was
such a successful successful idea now
looking at that okay he wants to play
Bishop d6 and exchange one of the
bishops
yeah I'm not sure that our can can
really avoid it but I want to do is I
want to play Bishop c4 try to play
against the six bone
but this is not bad actually take here
check yeah because of this smooth it's
important attacking the night then I can
go here and just get-get e5 it's not
easy technically but it's a bond now i
can edit it is it's not difficult for a
technical point of view i overlooked
something yeah okay I get it a key 5 and
after retreating I have rookie sick
center and other ways to attack the the
g5 porn
and his rook is very passive this is
important cannot enter my position ideas
just Bishop b3 and rocky 6 his night
doesn't have a a good a good post
yeah no move I don't see more fruit k 6
is deadly
yeah jacqueline no getting into the the
pin black resigns yeah I think him he
gave gave some headway I am by allowing
this this 95 and take on g6 business
this kind of structure should favor
white even even with this pretty young
in accurate way of playing check why
this is somewhat better but ok he is
solid and somewhere around here there
must be some sort of issue now F ibers
is excellent yeah he probably must play
some some passive move like this and try
to hold on somehow well it's passive but
still sell hard to break down in the
game after this g 5 f-5 i think black is
busted yeah Compeyson plus 2 already
this is best line and that's it's
looking like crap really again I'm
entering here yeah this is terrible for
black cami it's just defending passively
and I have the much much better minor
piece probably the easiest for him with
some around here to to maybe just if you
want to keep it simple just just play
some move like that and get to get a
square on age 74 the bishop when he's 6
and so on not much going on alright
thanks for watching